TO STAY AFLOAT STUCK IN LIMBO.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE, I’M
SANDRA SMITH.
>> I TRACE GALLAGHER IN FOR
ED HENRY.
THE NATION’S LEADING INFECTIOUS
DISEASE SPECIALIST IS SET TO
TESTIFY THIS MORNING ON
CAPITOL HILL.
I HAVE FULL OF STATES BRING BACK
RESTRICTIONS OF IT A SPIKE IN
INFECTION RATES.
>> Sandra: WITH SO MANY STATES
STRUGGLING TO CONTAIN THE
RAPIDLY SPREADING DISEASE
AMERICANS ARE URGED TO WEAR
MASKS AND PRACTICE SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
>> THE COMMUNICATION AROUND YOU
ARE SAFE AT HOME AS A WHOLE
HELPS SAVE SLOW THE SPREAD.
REMEMBER ARM YOURSELF WITH THE
MASK.
IT’S YOUR BEST DEFENSE AGAINST A
VIRUS.
>> THIS IS REAL.
PEOPLE ARE DYING.
PEOPLE ARE GETTING SICK.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO THE
HOSPITAL.
PEOPLE IN ICU BEDS AND, THEY ARE
AFFECTING THEIR LOVED ONES.
QUITE FRANKLY I HAVE LOST
PATIENCE WITH YOU ON THAT
REGARDS.
SO THIS IS NOT A POLITICAL DEAL.
>> Sandra: AS WE HEADED TO
INDEPENDENCE DAY WEEKEND
CASEY STEGALL IS LIVE IN DALLAS
FOR US THIS MORNING.
>> AT LEAST 16 STATES HAVE NOW
EITHER PAUSED OR PULLED BACK ON
THEIR REOPENING PLANS AND
ARIZONA IS NOW TAKING A MUCH
MORE AGGRESSIVE APPROACH.
IF THE GOVERNOR IN THAT STATE
HAS NOW ORDERED THAT BARS ARE
CLOSED, GYMS ARE CLOSED,
THEATERS, WATER PARKS AND
ENTERED TWO BIG BUSINESSES.
THE LATEST STATEWIDE DIRECTIVE
WENT INTO EFFECT LAST NIGHT AND
ALSO CAPS GATHERINGS OF THE
PUBLIC AT 50, AND TEN AT
SWIMMING POOLS.
THIS IS IN RESPONSE TO BOTH AN
INCREASE OF NEW CASES ACROSS THE
GRAND CANYON STATE BUT ALSO A
GROWING NUMBER OF
HOSPITALIZATIONS.
84% OF ARIZONANS AND PATIENT
BEDS ARE CURRENTLY OCCUPIED, 88%
OF ICU BEDS ARE FULL.
>> THIS IS REAL, IT’S NOT GOING
AWAY ANYTIME SOON, AND I WOULD
HATE FOR ANY OF YOU TO SEE WHAT
WE ARE SEEING ON A DAILY BASIS.
SO STAY SAFE PLEASE.
>> IN ADDITION TO A GROWING LIST
OF BEACH CLOSURES, THAT YOU CAN
ADD LOS ANGELES LOS ANGELES
BEACHES AS WELL.
THE COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
VOTED TO CLOSE ALL BEACHES,
PEERS, BEACH BIKE PATH AND
ACCESS POINTS ALL IN AN EFFORT
TO DISCOURAGE LARGE GATHERINGS.
IN THE MEANTIME IN TEXAS, BROWSE
ACROSS THE STATE REMAIN CLOSED,
ONLY OPEN IN THE DELIVERY OR
CARRY OUT CAPACITY IF THEY MEET
CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS.
THAT FOLLOWS GREG ABBOTT’S
EXECUTIVE ORDERS LAST FRIDAY.
IN RESPONSE ABOUT TWO DOZEN BAR
OWNERS AND PRIVATE CITIZENS HAVE
FILED A LAWSUIT, TRAVIS COUNTY
WHICH IS AUSTIN.
THE SUIT BECAUSE THE EMERGENCY
ORDER UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND
ARGUES THAT IT SUSPENDS STATE
LAW, A POWER THAT ONLY THE
LEGISLATURE HOLDS.
ABBOTT HAS SAID THE BARS WERE
SHUT DOWN BECAUSE PUBLIC HEALTH
DATA SHOWS THAT THEY WERE A
LARGE CONTRIBUTING FACTOR IN THE
SPREAD OF NEW CORONAVIRUS CASES,